par l'état rémy pointereau pour le
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
madame la présidente mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre
par calcul politique et pour calmer une
majorité incertaine notamment au sénat
vous étiez prêts à amnistier les
violences commises lors de conflits
sociaux en donnant pratiquement a permis
de casser dans cet hémicycle
il y a quelques semaines madame taubira
garde des sceaux n'avait pas hésité à
dire à l'occasion de l'examen de cette
proposition de loi d'aministie nous
sommes inspirés par le souci d'accomplir
un acte politique républicain de
concorde sociale
le sénat l'avait adopté avec des voix
socialistes
dans le même temps vous casser le droit
de manifester qui est un des droits
fondamentaux dans toute démocratie quand
vous réprimées avec violence des
manifestations pacifiques comme celles
qui ont permis à plusieurs millions de
français d'exprimer leur opposition au
mariage pour tous et à ses conséquences
rappelez vous les propos du candidat
hollande qui promettait d'être à
l'écouté des français
il disait moi président j'engagerai de
grand débat citoyen il y aurait ainsi
deux poids deux mesures dans les coupes
de la contestation
amnistie pour les casseurs répression
pour les manifestants pacifiques
et puis un matin on apprenait que
finalement le gouvernement ne soutenait
plus la proposition de loi d'aministie
communiste adopté par le sénat
nous nous en réjouissons mais ainsi vous
désavouer donc votre propre majorité au
sénat hier matin aussi le projet de loi
dit de moralisation politique était
présenté en conseil des ministres quel
bel écran de fumée entre une réalité que
vous ne voulez pas voir ce qu'ils ont
failli chez vous et l'opinion coin 10.6
dans ce malheureux encore entre votre
projet d' amnistie sociale pour des
casseurs
le projet de loi de moralisation
politique je vous rappelle l' affaire
dsk entre autres puis le mensonge
hantée de monsieur cahuzac et en même
temps vous osé annoncer aux élèves
qu'ils auront à nouveau des cours de
morale qu'est l'exemplarité vous donner
avec toujours ce même principe
faites ce que je dis ne faites pas ce
que je fais toutes ses contradictions
ses manipulations de l'opinion ces
mensonges de peuvent asseoir à pouvoir
vous le discréditer
au contraire et pour cacher vos erreurs
vous voulez dans le même temps aussi
discréditer toute la classe politique
disent qu'ils sentent dans sa grande
majorité fait son travail avec
conscience
les français ne sont pas dupes ils
veulent que vous vous attaquer aux vrais
problèmes économiques et sociaux le
chômage le pouvoir d'achat
l'insécurité vous êtes en place depuis
près d'un an vous faut redonner de la
consistance au mot gouverner quand
allez-vous prendre vos responsabilités
et arrêter de rejeter la faute sur les
os la parole est un madame najat
vallaud-belkacem milices des droits des
femmes porte parole du gouvernement
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs messieurs les
sénateurs
point trop pour répondre à votre
question le gouvernement n'a jamais été
favorable à la proposition de loi que
vous évoquez portant sur la mystique
sociale le gouvernement n'y a jamais été
favorable pour une raison précise que je
vais rappeler à nouveau par construction
nous estimons que l'amnistié remettent
en cause les décisions de justice et
donc nous ne sommes pas favorables à une
telle remise en cause nous considérons
au contraire et vous feriez bien d'en
prendre un peu de grain aussi que seul
le respect de la loi le respect de la
décision démocratiquement adopté doit
s'imposer quel que soit le sujet quel
que soit le sujet est évoqué et que ce
respect de la loi républicaine est sans
doute la meilleure façon de sortir notre
pays de l'ornière dans laquelle vous
l'avez mis à bien des égards pour
poursuivre sur les questions que vous
adresser au gouvernement portant sur la
cohérence de son action
monsieur le sénateur le temps du bilan
n'est pas venu et pourtant et pourtant
je me prends
très de bonne grâce à cet exercice tant
il est vrai que je suis fier
d'appartenir à un gouvernement qui a
d'ores et déjà à peine onze mois après
sa prise de responsabilité respecter la
quasi totalité des 60 engagements du
président de la république françois
hollande
plus encore que respecter ses
engagements
ce gouvernement fait front car en ce
moment gouverner c'est faire front et
donc monsieur le sénateur je veux vous
le redire la cohérence de notre action
c'est celle qui consiste à redresser le
pays redresser le pays dans la justice
dans l'égalité lui donner des
perspectives ce souffle qui lui a
cruellement manqué ces dernières années
lui permettre de se projeter dans un
avenir dans lequel nous voulons lui
redonner confiance
alors pour ce faire monsieur le sénateur
sachez que il faut du courage c'est ce
dont vous avez beaucoup manqué ces
dernières années oui il se trouve que
notre gouvernement a eu le courage du
sérieux budgétaire
le sel qui nous permette d'avoir comme
premier budget de l'état n'ont pas le
remboursement des intérêts de la dette
mais l'éducation mais la justice mais la
santé nous en sommes fiers
oui nous avons eu le courage de nous
attaquer totalement ce que vous n'aviez
pas fait la bataille de l'emploi en
faisant confiance au dialogue social en
faisant confiance le dialogue social que
vous aviez piétiner mais aussi en allant
plus loin en adoptant un pacte de
compétitivité beaucoup plus ambitieux
que vous n'auriez même osé le rêver en
adoptant une sécurisation des parcours
professionnels qui était devenu un
serpent de mer ces dernières années en
apportant des réponses à une jeunesse
qui sous votre gouvernance se désespérer
dans ce pays
nous en sommes fiers enfin le
gouvernement auquel j'appartiens
messieurs mesdames les sénateurs a le
courage aussi de faire avancer la
société en adoptant des réformes
d'égalité qui font grandir sa devise
liberté égalité fraternité
voilà cette question pour conclure mon
propos monsieur le sénateur et vous quel
est votre cohérence est ce que vous
aurez le courage d'adopter les textes
qui vont intensifier la lutte contre la
fraude fiscale
les textes qui vont imposer de la
probité de la transparence de la vie
publique
les textes qui vont garantir
l'indépendance du conseil supérieur de
la magistrature
les électeurs vous attendre